why do you think young people have
emerged as the voices with real power on
this whole issue because we we are the
ones who are going to live with this and
we many children understand more than
adults that it is our future that is
being at risk and we also have enormous
power as a young person you always have
like a natural instinct to to rebel in a
way and that it's very useful in a
situation like this does it ever feel
like too much of a burden to be the face
of a global movement I mean of course
and I I think I speak on behalf of all
the children and young people who are
school striking and organizing that we
are I mean we are just children we
shouldn't have to do this the adults
should take that responsibility so of
course it's it's a big burden and and in
a way of course we aren't forced to do
this but since we know what is at risk
we know that our future is being at risk
we feel like we must continue when you
look around the world there are some
countries that are taking action the UK
for example is committed to net zero
carbon emissions by 2050 is that
progress for you that depends on what
you define as progress if they are to
follow their carbon budgets to be in
line with the first women to say below
the 1.5 degrees of warming of
pre-industrial levels then I mean I
sometimes want to do they have like a
secret carbon budget that we don't know
about because they are being very proud
of what they have accomplished but I
mean that is not nearly enough if they
are to do their part
that target is considered immensely
ambitious and it was what was
politically possible do you accept that
even though that's incremental progress
it still counts I mean you could argue
that that is better than nothing
but I think that I think that is
actually doing more harm than good
because that sends a signal that we can
continue like this for I don't know how
many years twenty more years and that we
can continue like now which is not good
what are those hard truths that you want
politicians around the world to
understand if they don't act now then in
the future they will they will be seen
as some of the greatest villains in
human history and we will not judge them
easy I think so but I mean they still
they can still change that you have
spoken before about the effect of
anxiety around climate change on your
mental health can you just describe that
for me and what prompted you finally to
take action yes
I mean anxiety when it comes to the
climate crisis is of course a very big
problem many people have it and they
feel anxiety and they feel sad or angry
or scared that nothing is being done and
that we are in every bit of our everyday
life we are fueling this crisis and that
is what I felt
and I just kind of convinced myself that
I will
I was so desperate so I was like I have
to do something and and then I got the
idea of school striking so I decided to
just try it and see where it led and
then it just become became big it became
a bit more than big I mean it sparked a
global movement and millions of
schoolchildren followed you will need
did you ever think it was going to end
up like that
No if anyone would have told me like
maybe one year ago that this is where
where we are now then I would be like I
would never have believed them what do
you think it was about the school strike
and that idea that caught the
imaginations of so many people it was
just after a very hot summer with lots
of wildfires and droughts and extreme
weather in Sweden so many people were
worried about and concerned about the
climate like oh maybe this is serious
also because it is children it is young
people who are saying these things that
are saying like you're stealing our
future why should we care about our
future educating ourselves it's new if
you don't care about our future and I
think that is a very powerful message
and people many people feel guilty when
children say that